[Laughter]
[Music]
nation on Greg Alba what is your name
Stacy Stacy
Olivia Howard is gonna watch my face
that looks way better in frame than it
does out of room guys Stacy has is
helping me by distracting me very good
did you did you we're gonna watch the
Batman in the wash in the lost videos a
couple of them before we do that special
announcement coming your way right now
July 7th the real rejects will be
hosting an event at arena Center lounge
the theater where Stacy is the event
coordinator it's a really cool theater
we're gonna do an event where we're
gonna be interacting with fans streaming
some stuff there it's gonna be really
exclusive but we'll hang out with you
guys before and after and during the
event it's gonna be one crazy time and I
hope you guys can make it out I'm
getting paid $5,000 to be there out of
my own pocket
I sold some eggs it's the only way I
could get the money and it wasn't enough
so every check she gets to Marina who's
going straight to my bank a couple of TV
spots here inside my forum sweaty just
touch your hand it did it's really Royce
sweaty
oddly moist when I film with you I sweat
it's just I think my mind has just
programmed himself to be there I'm not
that intimidated by it only a little bit
only a little bit because you beat Josh
mokuba in the Shimoda it's a [ __ ]
joke crime fighters TV spot
again Messer up every time
maybe you just need a partner
all right I heard what happened to you
it's crazy could be ghosts stole your
[Music]
deal the chance you got
they're supposed to do
[Music]
she seems more intense the aunt gets me
every time
aunt gets it okay let's watch this other
one really quick then we'll talk a
little bit about it meet people new TV
spot we unleashed something powerful a
chance to practice together there is
another person anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
even with like mammal powers or maybe
even just a suit with no powers you know
I was gonna worry Michael Pena wasn't
really gonna be in this movie
looking at these last two TV spots like
oh he's definitely in the official
trailers we barely saw him so it's nice
than the TV spots they're using those
times sure like there was 30 second
moments cuz he's the one with a lot of
humor because I favor one in the first
one it's so happy that he gets a chance
to like really be promoted on these
teaser spots right now it's genuinely
funny and he's in a position where he is
like the audience where he just thinks
everything is so cool and wants to
participate I mean he doesn't have the
powers or the capability I'm so relieved
to be watching this film because it just
seems like such a delight after the
events and infinite I'm a sensitive guy
in some ways this seems necessary right
now for after infinity war because the
finiti war was a lot of weight to
character it's just like another Marvel
film yes and I kind of like that though
you know again it's these and not to
play on words here but no I'm excited to
see this villain too because I don't
know I mean I don't worry look I don't
know anything about her she looks crazy
I mean like in her like little like
world like she's all tripping out cuz
she's not even really there she's like a
phantom ghost thing I feel like the
powers are cool well what we've seen so
far of her doesn't look all that special
it kind of seems like a generic villain
honestly she's British the powers in the
suit like the whole look it seems cool
it's just when I was watching her hear
her then I feel like what people are
tuning in for this one is ant-man and
the wasp and that looks great that all
looks amazing do you think you're not
interested in that part of it
I am I'm interested in it kind of
skeptical that they're actually gonna do
a really good job with handling her as a
villain am I mistaken or Michelle
Pfeiffer's movie she is she plays him
yeah they like find her it hasn't she
been lost in the fan yeah she's been
lost in the quantum realm imagine they
pull her out or something or maybe it's
just a flashback
I think the quantum realm will have
something to do with some type of time
jump to do with Avengers 4 there's been
a lot of photos released on Avengers for
that show ant-man at the Battle of New
York from the first Avengers movie so I
think the quantum realm will have
something to do with that we'll see how
it all it's all gonna tie in it's kind
of I mean the timelines everything is
just kind of a jumbled mess right now we
don't know how it's gonna work down so
this is gonna give us some insight into
that all I know is I'm going there
disney press screening here I'll be
there oh I'm jealous on the date can I
come as your friend date III have a
girlfriend I know that's why I said a
friend date like like he'll make out
with him right isn't like angelicque
bells Stacy Oh Howard on Twitter and
Instagram she's a dear friend of mine
and what do you do reduce Italy I
coordinate events and marketing and
stuff for so you guys are going to do a
special event with us on July 7th that
arena cinta lounge we are going to be
doing a special ability guys don't come
out you can get tickets at arenas green
dot or you can follow us on Instagram
Twitter Facebook everything at or
innocent lounge so
yeah we announcements are gonna be up
there and plan to be here in LA on
Sunset Boulevard July 7 with these guys
John's not here but John's actually
right behind you is just staring at me
we're cutting the camera